[Música]
y seguimos hablando de la energía y
también del cambio climático porque
demasiadas promesas hermosas y palabras
huecas por parte de los líderes
mundiales esas han sido las conclusiones
a las que han llegado los jóvenes
activistas climáticos reunidos en milán
en italia estos embajadores de la
juventud instaron a los líderes
mundiales a despertarse y así tomar en
serio la crisis climática un mes de la
crucial conferencia climática de
naciones unidas- la cob 26 que se va a
realizar en noviembre en glasgow en
escocia para ello entonces quiero
saludar a mi segundo invitado del día el
esade santiago lorenzo jefe de la unidad
de economía del cambio climático de la
división de desarrollo sostenible y
también asentamientos humanos de la
cepal grasa hacían gracias ante algo por
estar aquí con nosotros en directo
américa muy buen día le pregunto a dónde
vamos y cómo estamos con respecto al
cambio climático que estamos haciendo
más todo no
buenos días sí sí la verdad que estamos
quedando cortos en la en la reunión de
jóvenes efectivamente se reclama que son
30 años de conversaciones porque el 92
se crea la convención marco sobre cambio
en bioclimático y ya son 29 años y desde
hace 29 más de 29 años se conoce lo que
está pasando y en estos 30 años
efectivamente las soluciones están ahí
se sabe que hacer es los principales
sectores emisores de gases de efecto
invernadero que son la causa del cambio
climático es la energía el transporte y
la forma de cultivar y crecer
el ganado en fin toda la parte
alimentaria rural y para todos los casos
ya existen tecnologías o prácticas que
nos pueden evitar
de llegar a los peores escenarios de
cambio climático
económicamente y son viables básicamente
entonces efectivamente si hay un reclamo
tiene una base fundamental muy fuerte y
si estamos en malas trayectorias para
empezar las contribuciones de los países
al acuerdo de parís que son las
propuestas que tienen para mitigar los
gases están muy por debajo de lo
requerido y en y además la parte del
financiamiento para adaptación porque el
caso de climático como puedes ver en las
noticias de todos los días ya está aquí
no hay dinero no hay recursos destinados
a la adaptación suficientes santiago
desglosemos un poco entonces en la
introducción que nos ha hecho empecemos
con la seguridad alimentaria cómo afecta
la crisis climática la producción de
alimentos y cómo lo vamos a vivir en
unos años
ese es un tema muy delicado
efectivamente hoy en día se produce
alimento más allá de lo necesario pero
la distribución del alimento hace que
haya poblaciones con
o
sin acceso pues a los alimentos a la
alimentación adecuada a la nutrición
adecuada lo decía
la chica que me precedió entre los
problemas del corazón parte de esa
alimentación pero no todos tienen acceso
a una alimentación equilibrada y eso es
cierto aún cuando se está que se tiene
la producción de alimentos necesarios
entonces hay un problema estructural que
ya existe pero al encima de ese que es
problema estructural efectivamente el
cambio climático tiene como
impactos la las crecientes
situaciones de sequías por ejemplo de
eventos extremos que pueden ser heladas
o pueden ser
lluvias en exceso que echan a perder los
cultivos y además existe lo que es un
proceso de de
emigración de ecosistemas es decir donde
antes se cultivaba por el cambio
climático
ya tiende a ver las condiciones
diferentes que requieren otro tipo de
prácticas para seguir cultivando lo
mismo y si estamos
entrando a una etapa de riesgo de no
poder cultivar o crecer el mismo monto
de alimentos y ya ha habido casos y
muchas migraciones que están sucediendo
que es otro problema con una dimensión
política enorme este después por cuestas
son migrantes climáticos
hablemos primero entonces en santiago de
usted decía que los gobiernos han hecho
lo suficiente no hay no han hecho bien
la tarea después
el acuerdo climático de parís que
realmente tienen que hacer para que
podamos ver pues los cambios no para el
bien de nuestro planeta y no calentar
más el globo terráqueo además hablaba de
un punto muy importante y es la
migración climática que seguramente se
va a venir a aumentando a medida que
pues se van agravando todos estos
fenómenos naturales santiago
sí sí sí bueno los gobiernos que tienen
que hacer no todo el cambio climático es
un problema tan complejo que no no sólo
los gobiernos todo el mundo tenemos algo
que hacer pero efectivamente los
gobiernos tienen deben tener en su
visión en su visión el bien común y
venimos de unas estructuras políticas y
económicas que han generado este
problema entonces se tienen que tomar
decisiones decisiones radicales en
cierto sentido de cambiar el modo de
producción cambiar el modo de consumo y
efectivamente los poderes fácticos
tratan de llevar hasta
hasta el último respiro su modo de hacer
negocios hoy en día y eso hace que
cabildean políticas como se han venido
haciendo y se reduzca la posibilidad de
hacer los cambios que tenemos que que
realmente hacer entonces si hay un
problema político el problema económico
también digo comenté antes ya todas las
las soluciones existen y son
económicamente viables pero
efectivamente si requieren un músculo
financiero fuerte de entrada hay que
hacer cambios radicales y eso cuesta
pero está más que comprobado de que los
costos a corto plazo pueden ser altos
pero a mediano plazo están más que más
que justificados entonces es una
cuestión de visión visión de largo plazo
que efectivamente la cuestión de
políticas de los tiempos políticos a
veces impacta y sobre la migración
efectivamente vamos a tenemos que
empezar a acostumbrarnos que va a haber
más migraciones masivas porque hay
regiones del planeta donde efectivamente
la vida como la hemos estado llevando
está costando más trabajo y los
ecosistemas ya no dan para alimentar a
la gente que se estaban dando las
condiciones de vida se están están
poniendo más difíciles y sin que vamos a
tener más ese tipo de migraciones y eso
requiere de acuerdos internacionales
porque efectivamente es un problema que
traspasa fronteras santiago rápidamente
tenemos un minuto para esto y tengo unas
preguntas que hacerle cómo podemos
llegar al tan anhelado desarrollo
sostenible además que podemos ver en ako
26 y si en esta cumbre si realmente se
va a componer entonces las pilas digamos
estos líderes mundiales para poder
accionar contra nuestro calentamiento
global y los jóvenes cuál es el móvil el
movimiento de los jóvenes que lidera
greta tumbes que tanto presionan a los
gobiernos
si voy a empezar con este primero los
jóvenes evidentemente el cambio
climático es ya una de las de los de los
hechos que a los jóvenes les ponen más
nerviosos hay estudios de que hay
inclusive estrés psicológico en los
jóvenes porque ven que el mundo que se
está viniendo encima es un mundo muy
diferente y hay una incertidumbre enorme
que para un joven es es terrible
entonces están actuando y están viviendo
con toda razón que nuestra generación
ya entregue algo mejor que solo para
parlamentar el problema entonces si
tienen toda la razón y están empresas
siempre impulsando que haya decisiones
ambiciosas decisiones ambiciosas que
requiere la cope requiere precisamente
eso la cob en este año tiene que cerrar
lo que se llama el roadbook que es el
reglamento el acuerdo de parís es como
una ley y el roadbook es como el
reglamento somos lo que se acordó en
parís se puede hacer
instrumentar y hay un par de temas que
están dificultando lo uno es el comercio
de emisiones
un mecanismo de facilitación que tiene
problemas técnicos muy específicos y que
requiere de una visión también de
política de altura es decir dejar los
detalles para más adelante porque lo
importante es tener un acuerdo y el
financiamiento siempre el financiamiento
el de los causantes del problema son
países desarrollados y los más afectados
son países en desarrollo saldía hay una
transferencia de recursos
lamentablemente lo tengo que interrumpir
ya se nos acaba el tiempo muchísimas
gracias por acompañarnos en directo
américa feliz el resto del día